nba murder mystery who got killed man  let's see let's see nobody come on  nobody oh no not kyrie no now who would  want to do kyrie like that we gotta  who's he last seen with  giannis hell no we need some justice for  kyrie who's a detective here man  somebody got saw off this lebron oh [ __ ]  yeah we got lebron on the case bro who  suspect number one you guys are done  okay whoa  retention's that high in brooklyn who  suspect number two this is getting crazy  paul george uh we got one more suspect  man ooh kd paul george and who  dwelling b  now who did brian arrest though because  if ron arrested you you probably did it  i'm not gonna lie damn  oh nah  anderson until proven guilty who  actually killed him who did it  hey d why would you do that bro who  snitched man  wow josh snitch that's crazy